this astronaut crew leading a new lunar
Mission their selection realizing a
lifelong dream puts them over the moon
we've spent our entire lives looking up
at the moon and now we're going to go
out there and look back at Earth
from that same distance
that is crazy on this diverse Artemis 2
crew three Americans all space veterans
and a Canadian Reed Weissman a U.S Navy
Captain and the mission Commander Victor
Glover the first black astronaut to make
a long duration space flight Christina
cook a member of the first three
all-female spacewalks and Canadian
Jeremy Hansen the only space rookie
aboard we won the astronaut Powerball
and I personally feel it's so much
bigger than me of my name being attached
to it after launch the Orion capsule
reach the moon in four days for a lunar
flyby This Crew could push deeper into
space than any humans ever before
finishing their 10-day Mission this
astronaut crew leading